♪ ♪
>> Greg: IN THE INTERVIEW,
NANCY PELOSI WAS ASKED WHETHER
SHE THOUGHT TRUMP.
HER DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE SHE'S A
WOMAN.
ME, I HAVE NO IDEA?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
WE WILL SEE.
SEE HOW HE WILL DEAL WITH
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU ARE A
WOMAN OR NOT.
I HOPE HE RECOGNIZES THAT A NEW
DAY HAS DAWNED IN AMERICA.
>> Greg: WHO KNOWS IF TRUMP
DEALS WITH HER DIFFERENTLY
BECAUSE SHE'S A LADY.
THE REAL QUESTION IS DOES SHE
TREAT TRUMP DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE
HE'S A MAN?
>> YOU REPORTEDLY CAME BACK AND
SPOKE TO MEMBERS OF YOUR
CONGRESS          CAUCUS
AND SAID THE WALL, IT SEEMS LIKE
IT MIGHT BE ABOUT HIS MANHOOD.
THAT'S A STATEMENT THAT'S
CAPABLE OF INTERPRETATION.
YOU CARE TO EXPLAIN WHAT YOU
MEANT?
>> I WISH I'D NOT REPEATED THAT
OUTSIDE THE ROOM.
>> Greg: I BET.
THE REAL THING IS WHAT PASSES AS
NEWS.
IT'S A BITTER SMOOTHIE MADE OF
WATER DOWN OLD NEWS THROWN INTO
AN IDIOT LENDER.
IN THIS ERA OF GOOD TIMES
BROUGHT TO BUY PEACE AND
PROSPERITY, THE MEDIA MUST KEEP
MAKING CRAZY CRAP UP.
IN THE OLD DAYS, SOMETHING
HAPPENED.
HERE IT IS.
NOW IT'S LET'S ASK SO-AND-SO A
QUESTION FOR AN OPINION INTO
WHAT WE CAN FASHION AS A FACT.
YOU END UP WITH FAILED OPINIONS
THAT DIDN'T MEASURE UP BEFORE
BUT FEELS LIKE FACTS FOR VIEWER
SEEKING VALIDATED ASSUMPTIONS
BECAUSE NO REAL FACTS EXIST.
SO WITHOUT NEW STUFF ON
COLLUSION, WE NOW HAVE OPINIONS
ON COLLUSION.
THEN FEELINGS ABOUT COLLUSION,
THEN FEELINGS ABOUT OPINIONS ON
COLLUSION, WHICH SUDDENLY
SOMEHOW BECOMES INDICTMENT.
>> EVERYTHING INDICATES THAT
PRESENT CAN BE INDICTED AFTER
HE'S NO LONGER PRESIDENT.
>> WHAT ABOUT SITTING PRESIDENT?
>> WHEN HE'S NO LONGER
PRESIDENT.
>> THE PRESIDENT IN OFFICE, CAN
ROBERT MUELLER SEEK AN
INDICTMENT?
>> THAT'S AN OPEN DISCUSSION.
>> Greg: THE STORIES ARE NO
LONGER WHO, WHAT, WHERE, WHY.
UNDER TRUMP, IT IS 1W REPEATED
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
WHINE, WHINE, WHINE.
DO YOU WANT TO HEAR WHAT NANCY'S
DAUGHTER HAD TO SAY?
LET'S ROLL IT.
>> SHE WILL CUT YOUR HEAD OFF
AND YOU WON'T EVEN KNOW YOU ARE
BLEEDING.
THAT'S ALL YOU NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT HER.
NO ONE EVER WON BETTING AGAINST
HER.
>> Greg: I AM GOING TO DO
THAT.
IMAGINE IF IVANKA TRUMP WAS ON A
SHOW AND SAID THAT ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP?
HE WILL CUT YOUR HEAD OFF AND
YOU WON'T EVEN KNOW IT'S
BLEEDING.
>> Dan: THAT IS PRETTY
MEDIEVAL.
>> Greg: THEY THOUGHT IT WAS
FUNNY.
>> Marie: SAYING THAT I CAN
SHOOT SOMEONE IN THE MIDDLE OF
NEW YORK AND STILL BE ELECTED.
>> Greg: THAT WAS ACCURATE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dan: FACTS DON'T MATTER
ANYMORE.
WE LIVE IN AN OPINION SOCIETY
WERE ALL OPINIONS ARE GIVEN
EQUAL WEIGHT EVEN WHEN THOSE
OPINIONS ARE STUPID AND MAKE NO
SENSE.
I REMEMBER WHEN I RAN FOR
OFFICE, ARGUING WITH A
"WASHINGTON POST" GUIDE THAT THE
REAGAN TAX CUTS HAD COST THE
GOVERNMENT MONEY.
I SAID HERE IS THE TREASURY'S
WEBSITE.
ARE YOU MISSING THIS?
DO I NEED TO EMAIL IT TO YOU?
HE REFUSED TO DEBATE IT.
WE ARE SEEING IT NOW TODAY.
WALLS DON'T WORK.
OKAY, THERE IS DATA ON THAT.
WHERE THEY BUILT A WALL, IT
WORKS.
NO, IT DOESN'T WORK.
ARE YOU IN A WORLD -- WERE YOU
VACCINATED AGAINST FACTS AT AN
EARLY AGE?
IT'S THE SAME THING ABOUT
COLLUSION.
IS THERE ANY ACTUAL EVIDENCE OR
ARE WE JUST GOING TO KEEP
TALKING ABOUT YOUR OPINION ON
COLLUSION?
>> Greg: KENNEDY, EACH STORY
IS ONE OF THOSE RUSSIAN DOLLS
AND WE JUST KEEP ADDING ANOTHER
ONE.
THE NESTING DOLLS.
COLLUSION BECOMES SOMEBODY SAYS
SOMETHING AND SOMEONE REACTS TO
THAT AND IT'S LIKE THE SOLAR
SYSTEM OF OPINIONS.
>> Kennedy: THE BIG QUESTION
IS WHAT'S IN THE MIDDLE?
>> Greg: CREAMY NOUGAT.
>> Kennedy: I WISH.
>> Greg: CAN VARY EGGED.
>> Kennedy: THE SMALLEST
NESTING DOLL, IS IT MUELLER'S
REPORT?
ARE WE GOING TO SEE IT?
IT FEELS LIKE HE'S GOING TO
HOARD HIS NESTING DOLLS AND
THAT'S THE THREAT THAT WE ARE
NEVER GOING TO SEE WHICH ONE
FITS INSIDE THE OTHER.
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE FACTS AND
YOU ONLY HAVE A SOCIETY AND
DISCOURSE BASED ON OPINION, IT'S
ENTIRELY SUBJECTIVE.
YOU NEVER REALLY GET TO THE
TRUTH.
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
OBJECTIVITY AND THE SEARCH FOR
THE TRUTH IS NOW BEING
DEMONIZED.
>> Greg: THAT IS SO TRUE.
HERE'S THE REALITY AND IS PART
OF OUR REALITY, JESSE.
IF TRUMP WASN'T AROUND, 87.3% OF
OUR STORIES WOULD NOT EXIST.
>> Jesse: RIGHT, IT WOULD BE
ABOUT NANCY PELOSI.
CAN WE GO WIDE?
THIS IS PROBABLY THE SCARIEST
THING I HAVE SEEN ALL DAY.
OH, MY GOD.
WE HAVE TO SEE THAT FOR THE NEXT
TWO YEARS.
THIS IS WHAT THE MEDIA IS NOW
DOING.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE NANCY
CATAPULTED UP TO THE SAME LEVEL
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE HER FACE
ALL THE TIME.
WHEN YOU SEE TRUMP'S FACE, IT'S
GOING TO BE NANCY AND THEY ARE
GOING TO CREATE A BIG COLLISION
IN THE MEDIA.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S A GOOD
THING FOR DEMOCRATS.
NANCY PELOSI IS EXTREMELY
UNPOPULAR.
TRUMP LOVES CONTRASTING SELF
WITH OTHER PEOPLE.
HE LOVES THE FIGHT.
I THINK IMMEDIATELY AND THE
DEMOCRATS OVER THE CLIFF ON
THIS.
YOU JUST HEARD TRIED TO GET HER
TO PLAY THE GENDER CARD,
SAVANNAH.
HE TRIED TO GET HER TO SAY
IMPEACH, IMPEACH, IMPEACH.
IF THE MEDIA DOES THAT TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, ESPECIALLY
NANCY PELOSI, WHO'S GOT A PRETTY
FIERCE LEFT-WING BREATHING DOWN
HER NECK OVER THE NEXT TWO
YEARS, GENDER CARD, RACE CARD,
IMPEACHMENT, THEY ARE GOING TO
DRIVE THEM OVER THE CLIFF.
>> Marie: ALL OF THOSE THINGS
EXISTED INTO THE RUN UP TO THE
MIDTERMS.
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT THAT
CAMPAIGN ON HEALTH CARE.
>> Marie: EVERY REPUBLICAN AD,
YOU KNOW THIS, SHE WAS THE FOIL
REPUBLICANS WERE RUNNING
AGAINST.
>> Kennedy: WHY DO DEMOCRATS
WHO RAN AGAINST HER DO SO WELL?
>> Marie: I THINK THE
DEMOCRATS GOT GOOD CANDIDATES
FOR THEIR DISTRICTS AND 15 DID
NOT VOTE FOR HER TODAY A
SPEAKER.
THEY FOUND CANDIDATES THAT ARE
NOT JUST LIBERALS, NOT JUST
PROGRESSIVES LIKE AOC.
THEY FIT THEIR DISTRICTS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF MODERATES.
SHE'S GOING HAVE TO BRING THEM
TOGETHER.
>> Jesse: THOSE MODERATES ARE
GOING TO LOSE THEIR SEATS IF
THEY GO FAR LEFT.
>> Marie: THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO.
THIS IS MY POINT.
REPUBLICANS SAY THAT SHE IS A
FOIL AND CHEESE UNPOPULAR AND IN
SOME PLACES SHE IS.
DEMOCRATS JUST WON HISTORIC
VICTORY IN THE HOUSE WITH THE
IDEA THAT SHE WOULD BE SPEAKER.
I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD NOT -- I
UNDERESTIMATED HER.
I SET ON THIS PROGRAM AND OTHERS
SHE WOULDN'T BE SPEAKER.
I WAS WRONG.
I UNDERESTIMATED HER STRENGTH
AND POWER AND IT WOULD BE STUPID
OF ALL OF US TO KEEP DOING THAT.
>> Greg: WE MUST LEAVE IT